So we've almost made it through science.
Now, we've discovered that science is really a foundation for understanding our
world, and it does not contradict our faith.
Well, that's good news. We've also taken a look at three really good pieces of
evidence that help us see that God is actually there, that we have evidence for
God. We looked at the idea of fine-tuning we looked at the idea
of DNA and we looked at the idea of design all of these
pointing to God in some way shape or form through the use of science
now I want you to keep in mind two kinds of students this week
the first kind is the student that has all this information and is super fired up
and ready to go with the best arguments that they have to their teacher who probably
knows more than they do about all these things, especially this week with the idea
of design because this is where the conversation between creation and evolution
starts to really come alive. And it might seem like this is
a good idea for them to jump off and start all these arguments and try to win people
to Christ and they might try it, and you want to champion that.
But at the same time, make sure that they do so in truth and love.
That if they're going to have these conversations, you don't want to tell them not
to. And it's okay that they can challenge their teachers, and it's okay to challenge
their students. But to do so with love, and to do so with the appropriate amount of
respect, especially for teachers, as well as engaging in the right kinds of
conversations. Now, the other type of student is maybe the one that really is still
not sure or the one that wasn't sure before entering into this conversation.
Now would be a really good time to take a step back and take inventory with that
student and ask them just the plain question, was this enough evidence?
Do you need more? What further questions do you have?
What clarifications do you need?
Now remember the reason and why we're doing this study.
It's so that our students can have a deep conviction for themselves about what they
believe and why they believe it.
And to also be able to communicate that in love and humility and do so relationally.
So while it might be really exciting to have some eager students to get started and
to get engaged in conversation,
help them be patient because there is so much more to learn.